[Music]
and I'd just say you a few little bits
about term being transgender before I
get on to the issue in the debate I mean
like sexuality gender identity for most
of us is something that we've known our
gender identity our conflicts with our
body are from a very early age and it's
really tough growing up if your body and
your mind is different and you exposed
to all the role models and gender
stereotypes of your gender identity but
you've been punished if you express
yourself in that way and and society
does portray men and women differently
and what in terms of clothing and makeup
an image is regarded as sexy or
beautiful and trans women are exposed to
these stereotypes just like other girls
are so just like most women we feel
inadequate when held up to images on the
cover folk but wearing beautiful worm
clothes and makeups does make us feel
better more confident about ourselves
and empowered and there is an additional
thing if you're trans which is your body
your genitalia for example doesn't match
what your head says it should be and in
a short talk I can't explain or give
justice to explaining the pain that
gender dysphoria has but in this debate
we are talking about what medical
interventions you can do to change your
body and whether that makes yourself
more authentic so there's three main
ways that transgender people become more
true to themselves and a fourth which is
the full cosmetic surgery which i think
is really only available to the very
rich the first is social transition I
won't go into that too much because it's
not really part of this debate but the
second is hormone treatment and I would
say that that is far more radical than
most plastic surgery and it's far more
empowering I mean your body over the
space of a few months does become more
of what you want it to be your whole
body changes your secondary
characteristics changes and your mind
changes as well and with a positive
psychological in impact so answering the
question that is this date I'd say yes
hormone plastic surgery to give it that
word does make your body closer to who
you are and so more authentic for some
gender reassignment surgery is the way
to go to change your genitalia to be
more and you know reflective of what is
inside your head to be I won't be too
crude but you know sex is only a short
part of your life but it is a very
important part and having your genitalia
matching what your mind is is really
important as well as not waking up and
going into the shower each morning and
being reminded that you're somehow
different so yes I'd say I'm having
sexual reassignment surgery it's also
important when it comes to plastic
surgery though I think that's more
complicated and I think it depends you
know I I was reflecting myself I do wear
makeup and it does make me feel more
confident but why why do I wear makeup
should I be pushed into this idea of
sort like there's an ideal image to
present and if so sort like should I
take something out if I had the money as
radical as plastic surgery I'd say for
myself no but I won't criticize anyone
else for doing so for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you